Cell salts would cell salts be okay to take in the morning routine. Yes, so cell
salts is another homeopathic remedy that's fine to take as well. Nothing that
we do, nothing you're doing with the rife goes against anything you're doing
homeopathically. Now, technically, the rife, having really getting down to it, is a
homeopathic treatment because you've seen frequencies. That's a homeopathic
is, it's the frequency of something. That's the argument against standards of
care have against holy opathy. If you take that homeopathic substance and you
send it to a biochemistry lab, you won't find any, so if you have, let's say,
Arnica, homeopath, you won't find any, Arnica in that substance. Once the
frequency of Arnica, that's in that. And that's how it actually works. And it
works on the basis of likes, your likes. So it can be a very beneficial
addition to help with symptom patterns and such and immune stimulation
as they just do. So